welcome to this video i'll be doing a
couple of three minute games on icc play
Grand Master roses here what kind of
flag is his Czech Republic now that he
while he played for a couple of um um
Federation's already i think bishop I
far as possible on here yeah this is an
old game of chrome nicks from from the
Bundesliga I only hope I remember this
correctly mmm-hmm I'll get you I'll get
this pawn back I think maybe it's got 95
hmm yeah maybe a maybe something went
wrong here this is really a really
really bad line for black but term as I
just get the porn back with a good
position but I think something is wrong
here not quite sure what exactly with
them I have more problems with getting
the porn back then I really expected
okay I probably can play c5 now and this
is a bit irritating okay I just wants to
get the bishop ok I understand it strong
piece on g2 g3 still um it shouldn't be
a big issue this position for for white
I don't have any advantage but it should
be should be all right probably a
screwed up the move on us there it's
really really really good for white in
some way not the way of how I play ok
can take now I can admit I can play this
and take I cannot take a seven or a
brocade okay so then just return yeah I
don't really want to make a draw I mean
maybe I can can set up this position
with before so the night on a five
pressurizing both the the porn cm2 place
be 6 i've got night see for all right so
let's can gain a little bit of bit of
space here gather should be nice Knight
to f4 would be great great improvement
maybe I should have taken not sure I
interesting is putting Eliza pawns on
dark square sister surprises me I'm
trying to get something on the default
if it takes I tape with the night and F
96 so he cannot really take time warning
maybe you can take no pain 95 or taking
g for now I'm 96 96 and the discovery
what does he doing now take take g6 as a
double check ride this is good hmm
threatening light c8 no I think it needs
to take this is it is a double check but
it doesn't really amount to much
fortunately highway 96 f 90 60 and now
96 this should be fine why didn't I just
take on g7 hmm now you can play g5 silly
okay
I take here is godrick g8 yeah this was
stupid I mean stupid play by me yeah
yeah very lucky 93 yeah it's really
terrible to lose this game so it was
excellent from for me check check black
forfeit on time oops yeah well can you
do yeah it's a very nice position but
some are lost threat here I mean this
this cannot possibly be good for black I
mean impossible I just take just take on
if I what I really didn't appreciate
that this this didn't this doesn't
really give me much this this is
discovered check I must take him I must
take only five film yeah I must take him
and then 96 aunt and cousins basically
this is terrible with the not only six
checking g7 they cannot play King f7
because of this meal I besides taking of
course I can take also I mean this is
just over yeah very easy alright so
let's request a new game and as I
somehow screwed up the opening
I know that this is right ah probably I
need to play fo first efore Bishop g6
and then a three yeah this is right yeah
I am so then then he doesn't have this
idea yeah I must play you for now this
is the ID me4 bishop g6 and then a 3
this is what was played in the scrum
league game okay yeah yeah already
requested a new game but I don't don't
get one okay game started I just put out
a request also 45 minutes so okay so
let's play Knight f3 playing in I am
here from Italy Ken Stahl I could never
play to my guess so it's a new account
no I can you Solomon from how this guy's
from know from South Africa actually
okay so I played a pretty real set up
here with e3 and e4 and in fact this
should be good for me already we should
be seven awesome it's not not an exact
move it's now been known you were black
ass play b 6i Bishop e7 and this is just
the worst possible place for this piece
he will need time to reroute it so I'm I
can take with the C porn or with you
pawn it's both them good for white ok
let's take with this this is more static
of course but I always enjoyed these
kind of positions he needs to yeah play
98 now I think and this should be just a
very comfortable advantage for white
Bishop on b7 is dead I've gotten already
made target on d6 not quite sure why
what always amazed what what people come
up with yeah probably this is it's not
an outright loss or something but I
would never if the f5 is just so weak
now you probably know I didn't play a 5
I expected him to play a 5 I mean he six
then is totally weak but this now looks
just just just terrible ok it's ideas if
i take that he could get so get the
square on d6 young ok
yeah still hard time to believe this
okay let's grab this okay I'll just take
the e file and then the right moment
apply h4 maybe I could have played each
forum alrighty it's possible so it's
that some direct way now to play it or
just just some normals be three or
something yeah let's let's support the
sea pawn
yeah if if I'm some are able to exchange
the night then the game is basically
over 94 and the writer moment the beer
would be good I cannot do it now of
course you could turn get them twin to
g3 and maybe this isn't so bad Queens to
g3 and also there's also threatens I h4
the queen is on g3 I mean age for was an
idea of anyway
ok i will this prevents h4 from the
moment so should I exchange on eh it's
not really so so great ok yeah well come
on let's keep it simple I only need to
be cautious about the timer ok now the
queenside collapses takes Knight a phone
f5 a saying I mean the whole structure
that like has put together yes quite
them quite amazing
yeah maybe rupees 6m preventing night
dt6 can take first but now I know this
movie j 6 and h6 I mean it opens a week
so I probably am when one or two more so
this one time warning yeah I'll take
this also check
yeah it's just playing on time obviously
it's what with the four points yeah and
yeah and the rook here black resigns all
right yeah yeah I mean this is just just
can cannot play like this okay and well
this is a desperation but black black is
simply tell all ya if he doesn't give
the pawn the computers on plus two
alrighty because it is just full of
weaknesses I mean gee fibers just cannot
cannot play this it must play King age
seven but it's it's it's terrible also
h4 h5 and so on so simply if back rank
chess all right so let's see if I get
get us another game another five minute
okay night h3 yeah yeah well I know this
guy at he's um yeah kind of always
playing on time and so on so on he's
probably playing whatever and tries to
win on time yeah i'll just keep
developing solidly this kind of stuff um
yeah I should give white them any
advantage but it's a not so terrible
fairly solid in the center of course one
idea against this kind of setups is
always an H pawn push I try that h4 h4
h5 h4
I wonder about H phone now you should
age for a group takes the same exchange
site but probably probably a bit too
much ok so just 97 normal lufia
exchanging the some bad bishop shooting
people shouldn't be here should be fine
i mean not quite sure what white is
doing here f6c air you can make play bf5
here ok let's first take him don't
change the rook and so probably take
with the bishop yeah and what now this
is so the interesting question f5 of
course he is threatening at the moment
winning them winning a piece so long
move would be f 60 now and it can't be
bad i mean just must be in pretty good
Kings Indian for me I've got the ideal
piece formation and the classical set up
with e 76 bishops and the night see em
okay we always try to block it
understandably I could take but not sure
if it down if it is great yeah probably
just prepare b5 even with the king of
the center it doesn't really doesn't
really matter it should be the way to
play okay is trying to block this so
yeah probably i should go for long
castles now yeah he wants to exchange
the bishop with the group G for ya I'm
not sure this is so a proper plan for
white it's a very time consuming not
sure maybe I can open up the position to
my advantage if you place really Bishop
g4 let's like taking an f5 could be a
could be an ADM so how to continue okay
let's just keep it simple take the H
file to activate the Roku so 11 idea
could be now Bishop burn the bishop
maneuver Bishop to a 5 d 8 a-5 get rid
of the bad bishop
bit down long time aha you prevented
this still the bishop is better on see
737 probably look F for Bishop is 6mm
look ff2 I mean of course look F to be
should be six rook f1 should be seven
yeah some some big exchange okay yeah
well I'm certainly all right this it's a
good position for the Queen on g4 only
issue is so the time you as it is so
often and this I don't understand it all
why would he lock the Kings side now I
can exchange the the bishop and should
be a should be really better time war
jack okay it's not a big deal probably
oh it is a big deal 25 25 I should have
played immediately would have been much
better probably winning even check
yeah this is still fine of course but um
other the other other way around it was
just much better so what does it protect
III Queen d2 I can just take g 3j if
they don't you can't really move
anything I can I think I'm improve the
the king yeah the Queen exchange
certainly wins but i'm not sure if it's
the best move man i can need to speed up
here okay yeah well maybe i should have
invested in a bit of time to find
something something even more convincing
this is so i have 95 of course 1095 now
that we would still have the game
continues with wood which really is this
it's not enough so you can try a silly
time plays again now winning this phone
I'm trying to add still nothing the
right of course check check check check
yeah I managed to spoil this within nine
seconds or whatever on the clock what is
he doing is very slow game garage yeah
yeah well I will note i'm simply m yeah
i'm not resigned because he won against
me tons of times with them rookie
against rookie and stupid stuff so i
want to show any fair play in myself
simply not conform okay so game started
all three minute game um k deform this
is the Grandmaster from France burek I'm
not quite sure about the pronunciation
okay so Budapest don't don't get that
too often against title players it's
probably not so bad but still fairly
unpopular
I have this set up against the budapest
and i always had pretty good good
results so easy to play and shot give
white a little bit of an advantage
simply because of them the better
influence in the center like always has
this problem with a d5 pawn I had a d5
point where i can always sticks a piece
and nth it's difficult would like to to
get rid of it okay okay let's just
centralized you probably wants to play
night c 5 & a 5 but then i have like b5
n95 which should be it should be quite
okay okay let's maybe put the CM to get
be fine to the two-game also really can
check with the sea por now and get some
nice pressure on the C file so
surprising me surprises me yeah what now
F for evening your for it's not bad it's
nights are now are doing nothing in the
position night c5 are not behind fair
probably it sir that's too early might
be five now yeah why not so should I
play you for now or not stop clear pile
up here i am a pileup on the sea por now
should be fine we move the seaport i can
just take these six
Roxy 3 not quite getting out this was
the great idea okay while it protects
the pawn yeah I only need to be cautious
not to also expand here so obviously
very nice for white but some still not
done something decisive ok c 6 mm time
warning ya need to get out of this
diagonal here and cover some squares f3h
3 and so on yeah it looks nice but how
do you actually win this now it's not
easy I at least I don't see a term of
hand yeah man TC got out of this not
sure what I should have done differently
I mean probably I'm still okay but it's
not not exactly the refutation of his
really not great play
they all night see one to get to get rid
of this piece and the night is not doing
much at the moment this is why I'm still
fine I think so difficult with the
little little time sometimes to to
assess this yeah I just need to help
that my king should be should be able to
to grab this yeah this should be four
and then I'll get the pawn so it's a
winning endgame probably winning I'm not
should not one hundred percent sure okay
well one thing is sure I won't lose I
get the H porn check check check check
game rah yeah yeah the time I was just
just realizing that it's the wrong the
wrong corner am for the bishop so I
probably can always take take they have
six at porn and draw this all right yeah
not a bad game I mean the only question
is how to improve here I mean this this
must be must be brilliant for what
Bishop g4 ah we should reform oh yeah I
must play Bishop g4 him didn't really
think about this mmm Cupid yeah he needs
to play a five then this is the problem
and then is so weakened it's too much d
6 square let me let me show this briefly
because it's really constructive here
this position if i go here he needs to
play a five otherwise i just grabbed the
pond f5 I can play whatever probably
here and then there's this idea and f5
or so weak like when t3e form this is
just the extra weakness that I need yeah
yeah this is good this is good very good
the computer is on plus 2 here plus 2
with an equal material but okay this is
just just an amazing piece all right
yeah I hope you enjoyed this brief list
blitz session and i'll be back with new
videos so yeah on a daily basis try at
least